♪ I said crippled donkey
Mel Brooks book train ♪
♪ bats on my knees ♪
♪ Penicillin trapdoor
laser currency beans ♪
(funky rock music)
- [Peele] Noah Sanders,
here for the job interview.
- Please take a seat, Mr.
Weinstein will see you next.
(lounge music)
(sighs)
- Job interviews huh? Never fun.
Okay. I get it. Stay focused.
Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
(laughter)
Oh, that's a big laugh.
(Peele sighs)
- [Weinstein] Oh no.
- [Adam] I did it.
- No you didn't.
(interviewer and interviewee
laughing hysterically)
- Geez, is this a job
interviewer or the
Carol Burnett show?
You know what I mean?
(both laughing)
- I can't-
- Oh, sir, sir, sir, sir
- Oh my God. That is too rich.
- [Adam] Oh, wow.
- [Key] Thanks so much
for coming in Adam.
- [Adam] Of course.
And you better stay away
from that Chinese food.
- [Key] Oh my god,
you got that right.
That's doing a
number on my stomach.
(martial arts shouting)
(Adam grunts)
- Here's your fortune. You're
gonna be sick in a half-hour.
(men cackling)
- Oh my gosh. What an
absolute delight, Adam.
- It's been great. And you-
Can I tell you
something real quick?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I don't even care
if I get this job
'cuz I know I've made
a friend for life.
- [Key] What a
terrific attitude.
What a great goddamn attitude.
- [Adam] Yeah.
- You son of a
gun. You know what?
Right quick before you leave,
I want to give you something.
- [Adam] No sir, I can't
take any more gifts.
This whole thing
has been a gift.
- [Key] My brother passed away.
(solemn music)
21 years ago.
We were estranged
and he became ill,
and he gave this to me
as a peace offering.
(Adam sighs)
And then one day when
we were on the ocean
he fell overboard.
On a boat very much
like this one and died.
- [Key] I saw him struggling
all the way as a riptide
just pulled him down.
- That bitch ocean
- Would you please
accept this as a token
of my gratitude for you
bringing joy back into my life?
- [Adam] Under any other
circumstance, I would refuse.
But I will accept
this gift today.
Because I know how
much it means to you.
So I will.
- Thank you.
- Ahoy matey.
(both snorting)
- (laughing) Ahoy matey?
(laughs)
- How is that funny?
(laughing)
- Bernadette, Bernadette, are
you hearing any of this guy?
- Oh my god.
- This guy- how do you keep
a straight face all day?
(cackling)
- She's- she's sweet. Sweeter
than pie. Sweeter than pie.
- Oh my God. God dammit,
I love your (beep) energy.
- Well what can I say, sir?
I am solar powered.
(Key squeals into a laugh)
- Really? You like
that one, huh?
- Oh, thanks so
much, Adam. Terrific.
Best interview I've ever been
a part of in my entire life.
Okay. Who's next?
You? Ready? Let's go.
Chop, chop. Here we go.
(clapping)
Come on. Let's go.
(claps)
- [Peele] Okay. Woohoo! Hoo!
Requesting permission
to come on board, sir.
Hi, Noah Sanders is the name.
I'm sorry to hear
about your brother.
Maybe we can get some
Chinese food after this?
- All right, all right.
Okay. Take it easy.
Jeez. Settle down turbo.
(audience applauds)
(funky guitar music)
♪ Got a pocket full of funky
with a peppermint twist. ♪
♪ She's a cold, shifty mama
blastin' off on the flip ♪
♪ Iridescent pork belly
galactic super train ♪
♪ Mama sister playground with
a straw daddy cane (uh huh) ♪
♪ Gotta get it up (hey) ♪
♪ Gotta get it up (uh huh) ♪
♪ Gotta get it down (hey) ♪
♪ Gotta make it strong ♪
♪ Got that quick dip crayon
earthquake jet pack on a bun ♪
♪ Locomotive supernova
Spanish Harlem sun ♪
♪ Slick crawfish solar blast
with phosphorescent brain ♪
♪ Who's that mama squat town
deep fried Detroit soda train ♪
♪ Gotta shake it up ♪
♪ Gotta move it in ♪
♪ Gotta put it down ♪
♪ You gotta make it swim ♪
♪ Nebulatic comets
sanitation disease ♪
♪ Quick play tornado rip and
tickle beef sneeze (hey) ♪
♪ Ships planets justice
cannons, cables, and trees ♪
♪ Doctor's office penguin
shillings, railroads, and peas ♪
♪ I said crippled donkey
Mel Brooks book train ♪
♪ bats on my knees ♪
♪ Penicillin trapdoor
laser currency beans ♪
♪ He say Penicillin trapdoor
- Hey, what the hell
are we saying, man?
- I got no idea, man.
I'm just hungry and talking
about the galaxy and trains.
I think they buying it, though.
(song ends)
(audience cheering
and applauding)
- [Man] Thank yous
for meeting here.
- Of course. You know,
I was glad we could set
aside our differences
and you know, avoid
a war here, you know.
- Salud
- All right. Salud.
(rock music intensifies)
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Anthony!
(knife shings)
- [Peele] Nah, don't do that.
(Man grunts)
We're trying to
avoid a war here.
No, Anthony. No.
That's too much.
What are you doing?
We're just having a
nice little dinner here.
(thud)
Alright, well that's
just disrespect-
(Key mumbles)
Oh no. Not his hair.
And he had good hair.
Yeah, you're done.
You already messed-
- [Key] You know
what that means.
- [Peele] What's going-
What are you doing now?
His phone?! No, no, no.
Don't go deleting this contacts.
- Delete, delete, delete
He's not gonna know whether
to answer it or not.
You're finished now?
That's that's good.
Look what you did.
Now, we were in the
middle of something.
And now, what's going on,
what are you doing there?
Oh, that's permanent.
That's a permanent
silly mustache.
Ah, now he looks like
a- a sleeping musketeer,
that's adorable but
it's, it's ridiculous.
He can't, he can
hardly wash that off.
That's- Well that's-
Where you going?
What is that?
Nah, what the-
what are you doing?
(sputtering)
What are you
putting in his hand?
That doesn't even make sense.
- Yeah.
- That doesn't even make sense.
Oh, oh, Anthony. Oh,
that's hilarious.
But save that for
a slumber party.
(utensils clanging)
All right, what are you doing?
No, you're rearranging
the silverware.
That's just so mean.
That's- It's confusing.
It's confusing enough.
Well what the- Anthony.
Anthony, don't do it.
Oh, well, you know, the
salad needed a little pepper,
So that's good. So
that's- that's not so bad.
You finally did
something constructive.
What are you looking for?
What are you-?
You're putting the
silverware back. That's good!
Well, that's all- that's good.
Now he knows he can go
from outside to inside.
That's- oh, you're putting
a little jus in his hair.
That's good, yeah, jus it.
Jus it- Oh, now, well, that-
It actually looks better
than when he came in.
If he wasn't unconscious,
he could go out on the town.
So that's good, that's good.
(Key grunting)
Oh, okay, you got- all right,
wipe off- wipe off his face.
Yeah, yeah, and get the
mustache while you're at it.
Cause that's that's the
most embarrassing part.
Ah, he doesn't
ridiculous anymore.
Oh, okay, yeah, that's, that's-
Now you're helping everybody.
That's good for everybody.
Everybody likes that.
Nobody wants lettuce
on the floor.
- Spick-and-(beep)-span.
- All right. We done?
All right. You really
turned this around Anthony
There he go- All right,
and then you're gone, then.
All right, all right. He
won't even know what hit him.
He won't even know that any-
(dreadful music)
Oh no, no, no, no, no. Anthony.
Anthony, I can see
it in your eyes.
I can see it in your eyes.
You're going the other
way now, Anthony.
Anthony, it was going so well.
Well that's- that's-
that's perverse, Anthony.
I don't even know what
that- What's that?
What are you going to
do with that finger?
What are you doing- Oh!
Yeah, no. Not a wet willy.
No! No, Anthony.
Oh, we're going to war, Anthony.
We're going to war.
(air whooshes)
- [Peele] I'm telling you Vinny.
No disrespect to your
daily departed grandmother.
But my aunt makes a
pasta- forget about it.
Your aunt lives in
this neighborhood?
Seems kind of dangerous.
- [Key] What are you
McGruff the Crime Dog?
Come on, we're late already.
- Yeah. You, you say she
lives in this house here?
- The (beep) is the
matter with you Vinny?
You're being rude. Let's go.
(crickets chirping and dogs
barking in the distance)
- [Peele] Not trying to be
rude. The lights are off.
Maybe we- let's come
back later okay?
- She's probably
just taking a nap
after the huge meal
she just made for us.
Go in.
- I don't have the key.
You should go in first.
- Oh Marrone, she said
she'd leave it open.
Vinny, stop being such a
strunz and get in there.
(eerie orchestral music)
- All right, all right.
(door creaks)
(opera music)
(opera music ends)
- Surprise.
(acapella music)